[Music]
wait so what do you listen to um i
listen to a lot of different i mean
i don't even at this point now
it's whatever you like music is so
accessible yeah so like i don't like
like i don't never listen to the new
stuff
because all your old stuff is just
accessible yeah you know
right on spotify so i'll be like
listening to like biggie's greatest hit
so you don't have to go on a search yeah
yeah i don't know
unless you listen to like the top
billboard 100 then you can kind of hear
like oh here's some of the new stuff
yeah yeah yeah but if i just find myself
listening to a lot of you like what you
like yeah and that's fine i love people
like that that just like what they like
it's like i mean
what what more are you gonna show
someone that's already like listened to
a lot of it right that's how i think of
it
excuse me you know is that fair to say
yeah yeah yeah but i mean like i say
i mean i just think that
there's
so much music available
how do you even stay up on it it's tough
well me being a geek i am i just listen
to it like if it's something because a
lot of fans they'll throw [ __ ] my way
they're like yo check this out oh you
know what i mean you're into like okay
i'm into it that deep though but that's
just in my life if i looked at my
playlist on my phone it'd be like it's
so it's so eclectic it's like i don't
even know
like i have a playlist called
white guy music and it's like
but it's like and it's all
[Laughter]
it's all acoustic versions oh yeah
no that's that that's fair but it's like
i mean i should just go to this because
no yeah yeah i want to hear it yeah
because it's like um
and
spotify keeps changing the damn thing
yeah so like yeah so i'll have like uh
sam fisher
okay ed sheeran
alex road james bay james arthur
they all named james um
lucas graham you know james tw that i
got three james's on here jeremy zucker
you know i like a lot and it's all the
acoustic versions of their big hits yeah
you know and i i like that's a that's a
chill
yeah yeah
that's a fair playlist yeah but i i have
but is that your everyday playlist no
because you know what i it's for a
specific thing like i can't listen to
like i like i can't listen to rock all
day
okay that would annoy the [ __ ] out of me
i can't listen because
i can't listen to rap all day
okay like i can't the only thing i can
listen to all day would be like you know
it's like any of those stations that are
like you know
you know early 2000s to now easy
listening you know okay okay okay
it's like i don't
because it's very it's uh very universal
yeah yeah where it's like if you like
rap that's like a specific
audience but if you like rock you know
but but also like rap and rock have that
like it's that pound it's hard on the
ear after a certain time yeah i like
easy listening but i also have a chopin
list
really yeah yeah yeah you're the first
guest to ever talk to me about that yeah
yeah i'll listen to some classical music
some jazz i'm like you know oh you
should get anywhere playing if i'm on a
plane yeah i have a go-to chopin list
did you grow up in a strong music
household no not really but actually my
mom played the piano when she was
younger you know she wanted to be a
concert pianist and she was very good
but then life got in the way yeah you
know so i got into entertainment but not
she wanted me to play the piano only
child yeah
she wanted me to play the piano but i
just
i think i regret it
it's one of those things where your
parents are forcing you to do something
and you don't really want to do it yeah
yeah because they're forcing you to do
it it's kind of like the vaccine
[Laughter]
that's right you know what i'm saying
yes it would probably be good for me to
play them yeah yeah
so you know it is what it is yo so i
mean i'm i'm happy that i you know you
decided to do my pod i know i mean you
do a million of them or whatever but you
know
for for you and i
like
i don't think we've ever had a
one-on-one yeah yeah yeah yeah what's
good about podcasts yeah yeah that's
what's good because i was like
we always talking like passings and all
that stuff like we shared the stage
together and all that but i was like
we've never actually gotten to like sit
down you know and my my
memory of you
was it was a big moment for me in my
life
you know because i just had quit
drinking you know i was going through a
rough time i had lost my brother you
know so i was like fine trying to find
myself again i had quit comedy you know
because i was doing comedy that i quit
it after you know he died and i want to
say
you know something just told me just
like go see a show
and i'm from arizona and you came to uh
tempe improv and i want to say you uh i
think moe mandel featured for you i
can't remember the year might have been
like 2015 or 24 yeah it's a while ago
yeah a while ago you know but uh
and i never seen you go up before
and i saw you go up and i told stevie
this and he thought i was bullshitting
or not he didn't think i was [ __ ]
he's just you know laughing about it
you're the first person
to ever make me laugh so hard that i
actually cried oh wow no one's ever
[ __ ]
done that for me ever
and i watch a lot of comedy right right
like even today because you worked at
the uh you worked at the i was just
there a lot it seemed like i worked
there but i was just there a lot i was
just in
i was just in phoenix live and somebody
said a lot you stand up live and they
were like yeah chappelle worked here
well
i mean no actually one time they bullied
me to be a security guard for a
fortnight that's what it is i was like
damn what you need me for anyways uh
yeah so like it was like you know and
you know you were one of those those
people that made me go man you know what
like like i started to miss the stage
you know what i mean and when i think
about you and your comedy and i you know
as i've seen it more and more
like
it made me appreciate that moment a lot
more oh that's good you know it made me
appreciate it because yeah cause i mean
like
you
when i look when i think about you
especially on
on that stage probably the most
comfortable person i've ever seen on
stage
really like taking a long time to get to
that level yeah yeah understandably you
know so like
that's why i'm always curious with
people i'm like man that there's a level
of comfortable comfortability that you
have that even people that have been
doing it for a long time still don't
have yeah you know and so like like
yeah where does that come from you know
what i have no idea yeah you know what i
mean because that's what i was like your
only child yeah i'm only child but i
don't know i've always been like a
people person so i feel like that's what
it is you know i often engage like when
i'm doing jokes i look out at the crowd
like i like looking at people's eyes
when i'm doing things so it's just like
having a conversation yeah so i always
look at it like that and when you're
having a conversation you're comfortable
like you're not uncomfortable when
you're talking to
a friend or you're talking you know
you're just having a conversation like
this so that's how i do it you are very
comfortable in conversations yeah like
very i've watched a lot of your
interviews and [ __ ] uh you're very very
comfortable coming it like no matter
what person throws at you
like you don't have like
you don't flinch
you're comfortable with like asking like
answering like a question
and and
i think that's yeah i don't know if it's
that you just
hold on to your who you are as a person
that's what you have to do yeah because
you'll be on something like i admire it
by the way some weird podcast this guy
jesse patterson it's this old black dude
yes and he and he'll he tries to like
you thought he had marshmallows in his
mouth yeah he start he'll be like you
know he'll say some stuff like that so
you hate black women right you know yes
sometimes and stuff like that yes and
then like he was trying to like goat me
into them stop wow
i would just be like i think you hate
black women yes what was interesting
about that interview because i saw that
interview was the fact that like because
i've watched like a lot of people go on
his show and they break down they break
down but i was like you never broke he
wasn't gonna because when you know what
somebody's doing
you can't the thing is like
no one can really get to you
unless you let them
and the only person that can really only
someone that really knows you or is
close to you can really bug you and the
only reason why it bugs you is because
you expect better of them yeah right but
if i don't know you i have no
expectations no yeah so yeah you could
you it's like you came in there super
cold you were like you're like i don't
know this dude and it was like he was
acting weird and all the questions were
weird yes dude the questions he was
asking yeah it was so weird
he was saying like you you never
most people will be like why the [ __ ]
you asked me that
cause i
cause you know what's funny but you
don't do that after i did that
uh interview
some people were hitting me up like yo
man have you seen so-and-so on there
they got into a fight or have you seen
like you know and i was like oh i just
thought well i get what he was trying to
do yeah yeah and i can still make it fun
yeah but you know you made it you made
it super fun but also like you like
you really know how to drop your
emotions and just have a conversation
and you you know what i'm saying yeah
well in those kind of situations you
have to but you know not always i mean
sometimes you know like like part of my
comedy is like just revealing like how i
feel about things you know like i like
to like [ __ ] about things and complain
about things and i just like to but you
make it about you it's about me right so
it's like in these situations when
you're talking to somebody and they're
revealing something about themselves
yeah or sometimes people are revealing
something about how they even ask you a
question they're revealing something
about them so i think it's just about
listening and so even when i'm on stage
i feel like i'm listening to the crowd
you know i'm just listening you know
like they're laughing at a certain thing
and that that gets the timing going or
maybe they're not laughing because
you're telling a story or you're like
you know you're in a transitional moment
you know you listen for that and
sometimes i revel in the silence there
was something there was something you
said uh
it was i think it was just one day at
the store because i mean i you know
whenever i was a you know around i just
kind of just chill and like let people
have their conversations but um
there was something that happened a
comic got off stage
and said
oh they they got off stage they're like
yo this person up front
wasn't laughing at all but came up to me
was like
yeah you i really loved you and they
were kind of like offended by that and
you said
what's wrong with that yeah they still
have fun
they may not have shown it in the way
that you want it and the way that you
want it it's almost like a selfish thing
you know which i thought was like i
thought that was an interest interesting
uh
way to [ __ ] put that well you know
what our perspective you know you know
what's weird is like
i mean
we're
a a comedy show is like an audience full
of people that the only thing the first
thing they have in common is the fact
that they've decided to come to a comedy
show but other than that
we don't know what kind of day these
people are having we don't know what
economic backgrounds they're from we
don't know their political affiliations
i mean there's people in the crowd that
are just like
they could be thinking all kind of crazy
stuff 100 and then the job is to like
make all these people
like
laugh together agree on a subject and
that's the the magic of it yeah so it's
like
yeah you kind of just like
you're like what's wrong with it so
yeah that means
you did the thing
yeah yeah yeah yeah but i mean you know
as a comic you think like the the
respect they just oh you they owe you
the response you wanted
if they're not if they're not shaking
their shoulders
like this you're like what are
[Laughter]
because you're like what the [ __ ] like
and then they come over and say you had
it yeah i had a great time i really
enjoyed your set you were always just
like [ __ ] and it's like what why did
you show that it's like well i guess
them telling you that why is that not
enough we're always obsessing over the
the the one person in the crowd that's
not laughing yeah
that's the one we obsess you're like i
mean they're not having a good time yeah
you look you're just like wow some
people don't show emotions but see
sometimes i'm i'm with that too
sometimes i'll be like i'm gonna get
this person
you know i don't care whatever happens
but you gonna laugh
i think that's just instinct yeah yeah
yeah you know i think that's just
instinct for a [ __ ] to be like
hey you
right there insecurities yes and we have
that yeah but i thought that's all we
are it's just a bunch of insecure
creatures oh yeah 100 percent i mean
looking to be heard yeah
like i i agree with that 1000
i mean like
the way i've understood been able to
understand myself
is through comedy like understand all my
insecurities and all that [ __ ] is by
going out on stage
well
i mean
i deal with a lot of things on stage
you know it's like it's why i laugh at
my own jokes because
they're for me
yeah you know what i mean like i'm doing
this for me i'm not you know and so
this i think the job you know it's like
of stand-up is to explain to the crowd
why
you think this is funny
and they're either going to agree or
disagree and sometimes they even
disagree with laughter yes but that's
what to me the point of what i'm doing
on stage as as i'm you know
i think this is funny and then i go oh i
have to explain to them why i think it's
funny that's a joke i'll beat your ass
yeah just kidding sorry
meatball i'm just kidding
really
[Applause]
so that's even worse i wish it was a
phone call so instead of it being a
phone call he was like i'm actually
watching the video right again i'm just
laughing at fighting kid right now
yeah
y'all keep going y'all do y'all things
out of here
get your ass out of here
the worst audience member ever
i know that's the one we need to make
right you're the one you're the one he's
the one
imagine you look out on a crowd yeah and
you're on stage and somebody's doing
like this yeah oh my god
see that's another thing too when a
[ __ ] is just texting it's like
oh do you want to say something or do
you not because you have that [ __ ] i
wish people i just wish people wouldn't
bring their phones to shows anyway yeah
it's like like we just enjoy this
experience
i hate when people you see people
recording or taking pictures it's like
people just have to share everything
everything oh okay yeah so that's what
that's what i was getting to
so uh
you know another thing i'd noticed
about you and i hope this is a fair
comparison for you
but
the way you talk about things and the
way you own things as to like you make
it like about this
how i think right right this is this is
all me yeah you know uh
patrice o'neill was really good at that
yeah yeah yeah and i noticed you you
have that like i'm not saying you're
like patrice but that i get it you know
what you're like the fourth person that
has said that to me
like really like yeah yeah yeah that
have been like you remind me of this
style and i get it it's a compliment you
know yeah yeah yeah it's not saying yeah
it's just the same but it's like i get
it yeah it's just you're really really
good about owning the what what you
believe in and you can you fully
commit you have to commit to what the
[ __ ] you're talking about and you're
like but also like your explanations
you know correct me if i'm wrong are so
good to where it's like how can you
argue that well the point is this this
is what i'm saying though it's like
that's what i'm saying like this is what
happened to me this is why i think it's
funny this is my thought process for
this now the crowd
is going to if you explain it well
enough their laughter is them either
agreeing with you or thinking you're
crazy
true but either way they're laughing
100 that's the whole point of it you
know what i mean so it's like i don't
necessarily want agreement i just want
them to understand
you know i think that's what people look
for a lot of times yeah i just want i'm
only nine i'm only nine years in yeah
yeah you know what i mean like you know
there's so much room to go i'm a
nine-year-old in comedy oof we say it
like that right yeah
yeah i'm i'm barely 20 i think but still
but still but i mean like but in in the
terms of comedy
that's that's a lot of knowledge you
know what i mean yeah but but the thing
is it's like
it doesn't matter because what we're
talking about is like a skill what we're
talking about is like techniques and uh
of how to do it and how to tap into like
letting the people know this is how i
feel as opposed to like just going what
do i think i think this is funny it's
like it's more than that you know you
want people to know how you feel about
things there's no right or wrong way
this isn't my thing it's like i just
want this is how i feel about this and
sometimes you can change it up so it's
like if i'm talking about something that
happened to me i could be like i'm
performing it as like oh i was annoyed
by this or you could be performing it
like i actually really enjoyed this but
either way you want to express that
emotion and feeling to the crowd yeah so
they can they can be like they're going
to enjoy oh he really oh he really loved
that even it could be something just
completely ridiculous yeah you know it
could be something really really they go
like why would he enjoy that that's why
they're laughing that's what yeah yeah
yes that's where it comes in that's
where it comes in or somebody else might
be like oh man totally agree with this
guy and then they're laughing because of
that or somebody else could be like this
guy's a this what this guy's an idiot
yeah yeah because there's so many
different there's so many different
levels it's like like so you have to
just you just have to make sure that you
have a clear
point of view and your point of view is
very clear yeah your point of view wait
so sometimes it is sometimes it isn't
but did you go this was just funny like
a funny you know what i mean sometimes
that's sometimes that's something
somebody has too it's like they're just
funny like a funny way of saying things
and it's like so it's trying to find
that combination that's what i'm just
you know i and my thing is i always love
to
find the root
of like things about people especially
you know where there's these certain
things that i admire about a person
i'm always like trying to like just i
was curious of the root of it all you
went to ucla no i went to usc for usc
but i didn't ever graduate never
graduated but like i'm from l.a yeah i
know you're born
right or died l.a and um
i guess i'm just curious is like
being an only child
and having the level of insight
that you do
because i guess sometimes you can like
bounce off siblings
you know when it comes to certain things
to kind of understand the big big
picture of things because you have so
many different
you know
avenues when you have brothers and
sisters
like for you
like yeah like where did that come from
yeah i don't know i just you know i i
just think that i was alone a lot cause
my mom was working single parent only
child and i just
you know i had a
rich imagination
when you're by yourself you know and
just
you know i just i don't know i just
never been afraid to like
like explore ask questions
i don't mind being wrong you know
because that's the whole point of by
asking questions like i'm not saying
something because i feel like i'm right
maybe i'm saying something because i
want to find out what the truth is yeah
you know and then once i find out that
truth i might be like man i know why did
i think about it like that yeah you know
you know and so i just think like just
being open to gathering information and
listening to people i think is where
that all comes from yeah no yeah because
i i believe you
have a strong opinion but also you
you're
also willing to learn at the same time
and not everybody has both of those yeah
but
yeah you know it's it can be tough too
though because how you say something
like i'm very confident about something
that i'm saying so somebody might take
that as being like oh you think you know
everything and i'm just like no i'm not
saying i know everything i just know
about what i'm saying right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah but if you want to
correct me please i noticed that in that
interview with the uh
that guy uh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] was it
jesse yeah jesse patterson or something
or whatever i noticed that like you you
didn't act like you knew it you knew
anything or like you just you just said
what you said yeah you just respond to
like so sometimes that's all that it is
you know i don't know man it's a weird
it's a weird thing like you know just in
in relation to doing stand-up comedy
it's like it's not an easy thing man no
standard economy is not an easy thing to
do and it's like it took a long time to
like
just be so now once you get to a certain
level there now there's then you want to
start working on well how do you be
great and that's like a whole other
thing it's like the subject matter how
you deal with the subject matter like
you know how many jokes per minute or
all those kinds of things because if you
look at the ones you admire you look at
the ones that are famous like what are
the what are they doing
you know and sometimes it it's like you
don't you may not even have that factor
you know and there's people that have
like specific styles like anthony
jeselnik i love anthony yeah yeah
but he has a specific style very
specific and he works on it you know he
has to work on it because everything has
to be precise
the words have to be a certain way and
so you know he has that style and he had
that work ethic and it it's translated
to him being very successful yeah so
sometimes though when you're like just a
stupid you're just a funny person
i know i've always just been a funny
person i can be funny i could be in a
room and people are gonna laugh
but that doesn't always translate to
being great
no yeah you know it doesn't know what i
mean and they also become a crutch it
could be it makes you lazy because you
just know i can go on stage and people
are going to laugh but it's like
sometimes i just like okay let me try to
hit certain subjects that i really want
to talk about and then like not be too
serious at the same time and still keep
it light
it's like so many factors that go into
but that's the i think that's the beauty
of stand up that's what i've
that's what i've really learned to love
about it is that like it's like a
[ __ ] like constant puzzle pieces or
like or constantly playing chess or
something to like figure out how to make
you know this a strategic move you know
when it comes to the writing you know
something or you know
yeah yeah yeah what you doing yeah
my job
he got so offended he was like i'm doing
but i don't even pay you directly
[ __ ]
well you know the thing
i think the thing every comic should ask
and it's just like something that you
know you might want to ask yourself
about your own material
why is it funny
like like
like literally why
thank you very much like sometimes we
don't know
and when you when you go why would you
if you ask yourself why is it funny and
then you might ask yourself like why are
people laughing
you know
it's like
sometimes we just don't know
yeah and you know you i mean you
literally don't know you don't know it's
like oh or they're laughing you know you
know and once you can tap into like why
this thing is funny and yeah know
exactly what this is really about
because sometimes we don't know what
it's about sometimes we think we're
doing a joke about like i'm doing a joke
about my cousin and it you know and
maybe it's not about that maybe it's
really about how people
you know
act when they go to a supermarket yeah
but it's rooted from the cusp
you know it's just like knowing that
stuff and it's just like so that's why
you got to analyze and i don't know
sometimes you you can overthink but like
i just feel like sometimes whatever you
do
intellectualize it
and then when it's time to do it you
forget all that stuff and you just live
and do it do you read a lot uh i act
yeah i listen to a lot of audio books oh
i can't do that [ __ ] i don't [ __ ]
know i sleep reading but i like i'll
fall asleep i love audiobooks and a
[ __ ] heartbeat if that book is not in
front of my face
then i won't i won't retain the
information i just feel like my eyes
start to get messed up when i'm reading
when i'm reading you know in your 40s
yeah i'm about to be 50. so it's like oh
yeah in march i'm gonna turn 50.
so
it's like uh that's why i listen to
audiobooks oh okay but i like escapism
so i listen to a lot of sci-fi fantasy i
love vampires drac excuse me like
dragons harry potter does that help you
paint a picture on stage
yeah sometimes
yeah when you like listen to a fantasy
world and you go you listen to an author
paint a picture
and if you can see the picture in your
head
i think comedies is similar yeah you
know what i mean you watch a lot of
sci-fi yeah i do did you watch babylon
five no i didn't no no actually i don't
watch a lot of sci-fi like that oh okay
no i but
i've only met one other person that was
brian simpson i'm into the soup i'm into
like superhero stuff oh okay into like
you know
vampires and all that because i was like
damn you get down with sci-fi
i guess not star wars you know i'll see
i didn't get into that let's see what
see this that's the age thing
you think so yeah yeah yeah
yeah cause i don't know
34. yeah that's the age thing like you
know like you're when you were young
star wars wasn't the thing no it wasn't
yeah it was the [ __ ] movies that was
coming out at that point yeah yeah i'm
talking about i was like i saw a return
of the jedi in the movie theater see
yeah yeah you got a different experience
of it whereas like mine was at home i
think if i would have got it in a
theater the way you did i probably would
have respected it or appreciated it a
lot more than what i did as a kid movie
stars were different then too i mean i
don't think there's a lot of like
big movie stars yeah because my
stepfather he loved like that whole
sci-fi
exactly what it was yeah he was he was
all about that [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
but it's like i i know i i don't that's
what i'm saying i know i don't know if i
was into sci-fi like in terms of like
star trek yeah like that kind of stuff
you see not and then it's interesting
yeah cause i i can't get into superhero
movies why not that one's tough for me
well i collected comics it's another age
thing oh yeah see yeah
i guess and you know a lot of my homies
do but i just can't have that kind of
imagination
for the superhero
you know
so then you're not into escapism you're
not you don't know how to get lost in
like you know like you know make believe
land and it's like that's what all this
is anyway though even when you're on
stage it's like you're creating you're
painting a picture that's not it's just
a slight
slightly real you know it's like yeah
yeah you know it's an exaggerated
version of yourself and we're like
talking in like absolutes and we're like
you know you know what i mean so if i
watch more superhero movies i'll be
better
maybe
you know what i mean
but i'm gonna report back to you then
superman's tight
but there's no right or wrong like i
said there's no right or wrong way no i
get it
but i don't know man you know it's like
say what's the point when you go on
stage you know it's like what's the
point yeah
what are we trying to get at what you
doing it's like are you just i just want
to make people laugh uh-huh i think it's
more than that you know what i really
really uh really realized
uh what made me really force myself to
like
just really be better as a comic first
time i did an all black room oh yeah
yeah cause you're yeah because and i
tanked
so hard and i didn't think i would you
know i thought i was you know knowing
you i think i would think you would yeah
yeah no no no and that's that's that's
fair to say yeah cause like you know it
was so funny uh
you remember casey currier used to work
bs stand up live in tempe improv
uh
he
and it was so funny because i just had
got done opening for bill burr there at
stand up live it did really really great
and he was like i know what you can do
in front of
bill bird's crowd he goes what can you
do in front of this crowd
and he you know he had who it was rodney
perry had he kept me up before right so
black
it was so [ __ ] funny and i remember i
walked out on that stage you know i had
the confidence i was just like yeah i'm
doing a set
you know and then you started to talk
and they were like get this white boy
off the stage
[Laughter]
they start bringing up sticks and [ __ ]
yeah i get it no it's so i tanked so
[ __ ] bad and that was the first night
and i had a full weekend with him
you know and so
i remember i i got like three laughs
because i counted i was like damn i got
three [ __ ] laughs and my homie came
up to me later on he goes dude
you got about three laughs and i was
like damn it it was tough but but you
know rodney perry gave me some insight
he said he goes he goes i appreciate
that you actually do stay you like you
don't try to be different you just stay
you he goes but
he goes you're not telling
you're not telling you're not saying
what it is about you you're just trying
to tell jokes they don't even know who
you are exactly
he goes he goes he goes you have a thing
about you that you're not saying he goes
as soon as you walk on stage he goes he
goes and this is just you with black
people in general he goes they know
you're different they want to know why
you know and i wasn't saying anything of
that nature i was just trying to be like
yeah yeah
you know here it is with a joke you know
what i mean like and i was trying and he
he goes he goes you gotta you gotta say
something about you you know and i
remember i went home cause i mean i
gosh i was embarrassed i i ran it was
tough oh it was tough it was because
like when you bomb in front of black
people
your soul
they snatch it they snatch it out of you
yeah and they're on it and they're very
vocal about it yeah you know what i mean
they're just like ah hell no you know
what i mean just like
you you ain't it they'll tell you right
then and there that's why i always tell
people i love performing for black
people more than i love performing for
like certain other crowds because black
people just let you know on site that
weren't good yeah but they're all more
afraid of you than you are of them yeah
100 percent you know that's the thing
you have to remember too yeah but i know
what you're saying i've had
when i first was coming up i've had many
experiences like that yeah where i'll be
like oh this is like i was like oh man i
had some
and now it's just i don't care yes you
know now yes but it's but it just i've
had those experiences and i think i was
trying to be impressive in this way
you know i just didn't do what i was you
know because they had a lot and i think
i did a disservice because it was just
like oh he didn't he didn't he didn't
talk about what we what we all thinking
you know what i mean where does this
come from like why do you like that why
do you like that because he he goes he
goes they know it as soon as you walk
out here he goes they know it before you
grab the microphone yeah they know you
ain't a regular black yeah exactly you
know and so uh i mean white girlfriends
like yo
[Laughter]
who's the white girl you dated yeah
where is talk about her yeah what is it
what is it no but i went home that day i
remember
it because i was like i got a full
[ __ ] weekend yeah and so i i went
home and i was like i gotta change it up
i gotta i gotta you know i gotta deliver
what i need to deliver you know cause i
was hosting as well and i don't want
this man to have like
you know what i mean so i went up there
and i said i just i just kind of smiled
and stared at the crowd and they started
giggling and then i was like
yeah i was adopted to a white family and
i just said that
and then and one guy goes [ __ ] i knew
it
and that's and then sometimes that's
what i said straight up so now now
they're on they're like okay we'll
forgive you for not being ice cube right
now yes
and then but then i realized with doing
that i was able to take them anywhere
yeah yeah i was like no now because i
just i really opened the door of
bringing them into my world but but but
when i first did a set with the set i
didn't i didn't bring them into my world
i was just saying [ __ ] about my being
there their perceived world in your head
yes and you know and that's the thing
and by the way and that's the disrespect
that to me
comics especially black comics have for
the audience
as if like
you know oh it's black crowd so we gotta
be i gotta i gotta i gotta you know we
gotta talk about whatever it's like you
know you do you don't these people watch
they watch everything they're gonna
enjoy authenticity yeah
authenticity that's oh that's all they
care for you could be you could be the
goofiest
dirtiest person ever but if you own that
well i was in the atlanta atlanta comedy
theater okay two years ago whatever it
was in florida
and i didn't know that this was like
as ghetto as it was
and i think
my fans didn't know either oh really
so i got people showing up
really black you know
asian white all these people you know
and i remember having to start the show
i'd be like hey listen
i didn't know it was this black
just
just to set the tone
it's like the dj's playing a lot of
music
emcee doing too much time you know what
i mean i'm like okay
there's too many guest sets you know i'm
like all right y'all
but i remember this old
favorite thing ever this old black dude
came up to me he wasn't old but he was
like 60s yeah put together a polo shirt
tucked in
you know and he shook my hand he was
like
poignant set brother
pulling him you know and i knew exactly
what he meant yeah you know what i mean
because he was just saying to me like i
enjoyed what you guys enjoyed about
poignancy yeah you didn't you didn't you
know what i mean he was like you weren't
pandering you know whatever that's the
vibe i got well that and i think that's
the thing with you know
just yeah with black crowd they just
want you to be they want you to be you
they don't want you to [ __ ] like
because they can feel the pandering and
make and i think pandering just for
anyone in general like you can feel it
feels icky yeah you're like oh you're
trying to like
be
sometimes like i i've done like
chocolate sundae and i'm done yeah go
ahead or like tripping on tuesday when
they used to have it at the community
yeah you should do these shows and
anytime there's a black show in
hollywood i'm never worried about it
because we in hollywood
like this like y'all we not in the
ghetto right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's it
sunset and what you call it
crescent heights yeah
you know what i mean but i remember like
like the dj i'll be like you know i'd be
like
i'm not that black
just
let's
turn that down
i don't want to give these people the
wrong impressions yeah yeah yeah yeah
cause then you gotta follow yeah you
know what i mean like all right you got
to follow up with that you just got to
just be who you are you know what i mean
it's like but you know there is like i
don't know there's a there's a vibe like
if you're at a funeral
if you're at a funeral you're going to
adapt you know you're going to like as
you talk you might be like oh you know a
little bit more sauce yeah yeah maybe at
a black crowd you might be a little bit
more animated but that's okay yeah i'm
just saying you like you know what i
mean you're you're vibing you're but
you're still trying to be your true
authentic self yes 100 it's not always
easy no i i mean i
listen i love the fact that i did that
show and also that was like right before
i moved to l.a i remember when i did
that i was like oh okay all right you
gotta you gotta like be you for sure 100
all the way no matter what the crowd is
as long as you're just
you and like you said yeah you might get
a little animated you know what i mean
especially if the crowd's like you know
really
bumping yeah you know what i mean you
say okay yeah i can you know just you
know
i don't know it's just
it's a strange thing man
like
my favorite type of crowd would be like
half white
right and then like a good number of
black people
but not too much where they make the
white people uncomfortable
but just yes
it's enough where they go when the black
people laugh they go oh yeah we're like
we're a part of this
that's the truest thing you know what i
mean
you know what i mean they're just like
they like to look over at the black
people and be like
oh this all right this is funny they
they like it so i think i mean because
you know because black black culture
sets the cool factor
for the for everyone you know what i
mean the lookover is the realest they're
like
yeah they look over like all right this
is they enjoyed this but if there's too
many black people there yeah then
they're like
yeah it might be like yeah
i don't know it's just some weird crowds
are different uh
eric
you can sing
well
i've heard you sing if i
i'm recovering from covet somebody where
are you good my uh no i'm not going to
ask you to sing right now
that'd be funny
a band comes in for no reason
but yeah
i'm not going to do that too i know but
when you're
you sing yeah but
yeah i always like you know i i was
always a singer i always sing in the
shower you know what i mean i'm that guy
you know what i mean i love killing the
karaoke oh you do you get down oh yeah
yeah i love all that i saw yeah because
i i saw your goddamn comedy jam or you
did uh careless whisper yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh that's a fun show to do i've
never done that one yeah that's a fun
show to do just for that reason it's
like every comic always wanted to be a
singer yeah probably every singer wishes
yeah which is they were you know fun i
mean but no you i'm like i was [ __ ]
yeah the whole time i kept going
[Laughter]
anytime eric seems
so yeah where'd that come from though
you just just kid
yeah man who knows i got like like you
know but you sound good yeah but i mean
that's just one of those things that you
get it's like being cute
you know you know you're asking somebody
well
how did you how did you how did you get
you how did you kill me you know you
said he just it's just
you you look you you either got it or
you don't yeah you can train to be
better but like you know yeah whitney
houston mariah carey these kind of
people they got it they got they were
given that whatever that is that muscle
they were given that and it just worked
out but not everybody got that not
everybody got that yeah and you got you
got it yeah so i'm enough i i'm enough
or i know you know oh and you you'll
keep up you'll keep the [ __ ] up yeah
yeah yeah that's why i'm saying i love
going to karaoke that's always a fun
thing i don't know if karaoke's still
going on after yeah because you got to
share a mic but i think they wiping it
off oh yeah true yeah they they got
going they got a new age way of doing
doing the karaoke [ __ ] that's always fun
what's your what's your go-to start off
song in karaoke start off strong karaoke
with uh i have a couple but like i love
can't wait to tell you mine purple
rainbow always my jam all right um
i like uh
um uh georgia by uh uh
rachel ray charles uh-huh that's a good
one uh jeremy uh pearl jordan yeah dude
that's a that's a tough [ __ ] song i
like that that song ain't easy uh what
was that other band that that they were
that it sounded they sounded like temple
pipes
they got a couple of good jams yeah i
might like i like um i like um kissing a
fool by george michael that's my go-to
oh that's your go-to yeah that's my goal
that's a good goat oh yeah that's a guy
mine's uh my go-to
uh the fray over my head
you're like you're one of those
[Laughter]
i've never gotten a good reaction
you wonder why black crowns are like
what's wrong with this thing
you wonder why they looking at you like
that you wonder why because you you came
out to the front
are you able to hit it it's tough i
listen i'm not getting over kobe but
you know my voice is i ran today
you know so when you run
what does that have to do with anything
well you run shut up
on the screen it says excuses
you run your your lung capacity
you ain't [ __ ]
yeah i worked out this morning i've been
doing uh i got a rowing machine you lost
a lot of weight yeah i'm gonna i'm on a
rowing machine so i do it i love it
every day
you thought i was gonna [ __ ] sing
that's why you stood up [ __ ]
sorry that was aggressive yeah really
aggressive
he brings it out of
like every here you see him you wanna be
like i will [ __ ] you up
yeah i'm what you're racist never i
don't have a racist bone in my body you
just don't like little guys yeah yeah i
think it's something about you being
little race
all right i'll hit you with something
oh you gotta you got all these
instruments and [ __ ]
i wish i knew the i don't know actually
know the fray on the guitar
uh
i never knew
i never knew that everything was falling
through that's all i give you that's all
i get
you ain't [ __ ] came up on the screen
that's what hey that's my [ __ ] i feel
like wow i feel like grey's anatomy was
about to come
how to save a lot
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's the jam this is
i brought out like the widest yeah the
widest song well sometimes songs get
stuck in your head like i'm always like
say flight repair
that's my goal
for no reason everybody does it i don't
care who you are
you just you everybody would do it say
flight repair
flight replacement i always tell you
there's levels to whiteness you know the
fray that's like
you know you seen that movie powder
that movie powder that that that level
that's the level of white yeah the fray
is fray is really white it's it's it's
super white because you know you name
those your white playlist i think the
fray goes yeah the fray would be one of
those if they have acoustic
yeah you know i like i like that i mean
i like
alternative rock yeah i do i like i have
a white guy playlist and a white girl
playlist too ooh white girl playlist
yeah i got a white girl playing this too
you know that's probably a good playlist
yeah they got some but i like that's
what i love about spotify and apple
music because you can get specific like
you just go in and search you can really
narrow it down
you go into search for acoustic
you get a lot of good stuff so do you
just have an acoustic white no no you
don't have to
just like you can just say acoustic
you know
that you don't have to add the white you
don't got to hang the white
[Laughter]
not a lot of black people do with
acoustics
you know what i mean
[Laughter]
you play like i
i i don't i tried to learn to play the
guitar i bought a guitar back in the day
you know you and it's like a guitar is
like golf yeah you know you think you
know you think you can you know i mean
like you maybe you're going like a par 3
course and you're like oh this is fun
this is fun but then when you get to the
big course you're like this is not fun
yeah you're like this is [ __ ] trash
guitar is the same way really learning
all these chords wait do you do you know
piano at all i i don't know a hint of it
maybe yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh okay
but i just i was gonna say a lot of
people say like if you could play piano
like you could catch the guitar pretty
easy easy and vice versa well i mean i
like i like again i i know like three or
four chords on the uh the guitar what i
love about the guitar is just all you
need is like three or four chords and
you can make something
oh god you can play the guitar you know
what song uh saves tonight
yeah so says
yeah
and fight the breakup it's only like two
chords yeah yeah
excuse me
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] both of you what'd you you didn't
say nothing but [ __ ] you too
so no clap for him
see i'm insecure about my singing yeah i
can tell you're sitting over here like
he's not really doing it
let that [ __ ] out
ah
[Laughter]
actually he had american idol auditions
and he nervous
you'd be one of those guys where you're
like your mom's outside like i hope he
does okay
[Laughter]
and you're gonna come out i didn't make
it to hollywood
that's gonna be you
ryan seacrest talking to me yeah yeah
yeah so what happened
so what did you know i just got shaken
up yeah and then you're gonna be one of
the ones where they do the little
pre-story yeah you know you know they'll
get people back yeah they get the
backstory
he was adopted by a white family and he
was like
and then
he gonna go into a [ __ ] tank you know
that'd be the one like ah maybe next
time this isn't for you this year
that's gonna be that story
those stories are always sad when it's
with the person they have they give this
full backstory you're like invested in
this person and then all of a sudden
they [ __ ] they actually stopped doing
that
anytime there's a backstory you know
that person is gonna make it oh you know
they're gonna yeah you gotta get they
they would do a back story they'd come
out they were ruthless
yes black person sucked yes they were
ruthless back in the day when it came to
that [ __ ] they were like oh [ __ ] i used
to get mad when they would this shitty
singer
walks out and then the mom
like you know before they go in the mom
was all like oh he always would sing to
me and you know and you just be like
yeah
that's your fault he in here
making a fool of himself
you [ __ ] him up you said yes to
everything yeah yeah participation yeah
yeah you gave him like is this good mom
yes
it's like no
i'm not gonna be like that
you got to be straight up yeah i believe
in that i believe oh i believe in it too
i mean that that's i mean
you know especially when you think about
today people just [ __ ]
they want to yes so bad that they'll
just take it even if it's not honest
excuse me i learned that from
um
when i was coaching high school
basketball oh yeah you used to coach
yeah yeah and it would be like
i learned because of like
two experiences like so one time
there's this kid you know you put kids
on the team it's like oh you're on the
team because every coach put him on the
team you know that kind of thing kid
ain't good i know he wasn't good you
know he sucked yeah okay
report cards came out
two of the kids had to get off the team
and then in the game three kids fouled
out so this kid had to go in the game
he lost the game
i'm just gonna be i'm just gonna be 100
i thought it was good now after the game
he comes he's talking he comes into the
off you know and he's crying you know
because he's like i lost the game for us
i suck today you know and on my mind i'm
like yeah you did you little
[ __ ] you know what i mean like
yeah you [ __ ] lost the game
but i was like ooh
i put him in this position
you understand yes i put him in this
position to fail
because he wasn't ready he wasn't and
then so that was one experience
because because sports is an elitist
system and it should be it should be yes
so this other kid i remember this the
best of the best this kid comes he he he
graduates
he's graduated he comes back and then so
he's still hanging out and he has this
conversation with me i'll never forget
it and he says i got to ask you
something he says why'd you put me on
the team
he's like i know i wasn't good
and he was like and then but once you
put me on a team and i didn't get any
playing time i was upset
because i was like
i'm on the team yeah shouldn't i play
and i'm thinking to myself you know what
you're right
and after that if you weren't good you
weren't going to be on the team
and period that's how it should be you
know it's just period you just you're
not good enough
and i'm not going to make you pretend
like i'm not going to like i'm not with
this participation [ __ ] no you know what
i mean like they you don't learn
anything they have to try out they have
to work hard to be on the team and even
when you're on the team you got to work
hard
to get playing time today like because
you people are relying on you it's like
that's what the team environment is
about
and it's gonna be winners and it's gonna
be losers that's why you have a
scoreboard
you know yeah and so
it's just there there's aid there's
there's stuff for that i get that like
you want people to be a part of stuff
but when it comes to competitive sports
this is about
the best of the best the best of the
best you know or trying to be that wait
so you you coach yeah because i coached
uh because i was a competitive
cheerleader and i also coached it and i
you know my least favorite age to coach
and just i mean
the fray
are you just going to gloss over that
[ __ ] i know you just go just he's like
he tried to like we're not going to talk
about it yes i was a competitive
cheerleader and then i coached it but
anyway and then we like
i mean
you need to open with that you're open
with
i know i should have started that yeah
the whole podcast was i was completely
cheerleading it was adopted right
[Laughter]
it's like but in that see
in that situation too it's like you
can't just put anybody on that somebody
get hurt yeah yeah somebody's gonna get
hurt yeah like you gotta i gotta trust
you to throw this [ __ ] in the
air yeah and i was like and if you're
not good at it i can't do that yeah yeah
yeah you know what i mean i don't know i
mean there's two schools of thought did
you coach uh
just one specific age or age range no i
coached a bunch like it was like high
school age uh
in the lower like park league yeah yeah
yeah okay okay yeah yeah you know it was
like you know it's
i don't know it's like the younger that
they are the more
you know fragile they can be like i
coach girls volleyball of like
grammar school age you know
and that was tough you know dude i i uh
i was a very very good cheerleader
shitty coach yeah because i was too like
i was like how the [ __ ] you not get it
and yeah it was like that like uh
like yeah i should definitely not have
been
coaching because i was like i'm not
teaching i'm expecting these kids to
learn
the way i did and i'm like that's not
how
that's how coaching works different
mentality different mentality and also
my least favorite age to coach
uh was college college girls
i hated it i was
drove me [ __ ] crazy why is that what
was the worst you know because um
a lot of them you know like when they
come into college a lot of them their
parents like you know they could get
away with anything with their parents
you know so they would try to do that
same thing with me but i was like i'm
not your parent
like there's times like
we would have a competition to get
prepared for like we'd have a
competition that weekend
girls would go come up to me they'd be
like hey i can't make practice because
there's this party
going on
at one of the dorms and i can't
you know i can't make practice and i'm
like
you really said that to me yeah you know
what i mean and so me i was just too
emotional
you know and i would get angry you know
like and stuff like that yeah well it's
about team building and about yeah yeah
and then i took myself out of situation
i was just like you know this
like i'm not the guy
you know or the the type of coach like
they need
you know what i mean because i was too
emotional as a coach because i'm like
man like because i was thinking about me
that's all i could hear about this
where's your work ethic where yeah yeah
because i cared about it so much became
the [ __ ] you know that sounded like
somebody that shouldn't have been on the
team though yeah yeah exactly but like
but like me not thinking that yeah yeah
you know what i mean because i think you
think if these people try out for the
team well it means that they care about
it exactly and that's what i thought
okay yeah so yeah you're gonna you're
gonna understand it you you you tried
out you're good enough to make it blah
blah so like yeah here it goes and but
that's not always the case yeah you know
what i mean i remember there was this
kid who like
he tried out for the team one year
and i was like i'm sorry you didn't make
the cut
and he and he was mad
you know i'ma show you you know what i
mean yeah i think well show me
[ __ ] you know yeah yeah then i
think he made the team the next year
but he always tells me about that but
that's the beauty of that yeah it was
like when i when i said i tanked that
show
and what did i do i didn't want i don't
want i didn't deserve for people to
laugh but there's a lot of people that
like they had a bad experience and they
never recover from it yeah but that's
like as a coach whatever you can't be
worried about that because you can't
save everybody you know not everybody's
going to have a great experience the
point is like the collective as the team
how are they going to do
you have to think about that i mean it's
tough
well
well eric there
as we're coming towards the end of the
pod i like to do these rapid questions
okay all right what is it favorite band
favorite band
um that's a tough one
i hate to be corny but i probably say
the beatles no that's fair yeah beetles
oh yeah jeremiah walker said that same
thing yeah yeah he and he said it the
same the same because it might be
because it's like it's like you know you
think a band that's like they're so
they're the most iconic man ever no yeah
exactly but they also deserve that to
that right favorite concert
favorite concert i ever went to was the
victory tour you went to the victory
tour yeah
yeah in 84 see michael jackson with his
brothers
at dodger stadium
yeah
wow yeah that was my favorite it was my
it's my first concert and my favorite
concert
yeah what a first concert i know i know
i was very because that was that was the
last tour they obviously yeah that was
the last twerk they did together but uh
well that was c that was michael didn't
want to do that tour i know but that was
on the heels of
his
height he had just a motown 25 oh yeah
where he did uh showcased the moonwalk
yeah moonwalk on tv and then the next
day everybody was going crazy everybody
in my grammar school was trying to move
walk you know what it was yeah it's
crazy so yeah so i went to that i i
remember that like getting the tickets
and being so excited to see that car
[ __ ] that's amazing i met randy jackson
the other day on on my flight yeah yeah
he was super nice he was probably in
coach no no you know
he was in first he was the first
he was at first i just cheated because i
looked right at him he started talking
to me i was like oh [ __ ] randy jackson
uh okay favorite album my favorite album
would be the thriller album damn good
because it was just i was a kid with
that yeah yeah and that was my first
that was my first cas i had two i had
two cassettes
with cassette tapes when i was a kid
huey lewis in the news mm-hmm i want a
new dream yeah i had that album that
album and i had the thriller albums the
thrill on top top to bottom yeah yeah
yeah great [ __ ] out yeah it really is
like it like it doesn't stop yeah yeah
yeah yeah uh favorite song to sing
favorite song to sing oh i said it
earlier it's kissing a fool
oh yeah yeah yeah you said yeah that was
your song so we also do
this last thing we'll do is i like to
make a playlist with every guest i have
oh and it's like it's like a soundtrack
to the episode that people can just
enjoy oh you know it gives them gives
them a vibe of that we start with the
fray
you know
uh so we'll do like 10 songs yeah well
yeah afraid i'll start with the fray uh
over my head yeah and then i would go
with you know george michael kissing a
fool uh-huh
uh and then i would go uh
georgia uh oh yeah let's go georgia uh
uh ray charles i'll do uh michael
jackson uh
baby be mine oh i was just gonna say
that real [ __ ] like
that song is [ __ ] fire yeah yeah yeah
yeah damn um
then i don't know whatever you want you
know purple rain please yeah we'll do
purple rain
prince another great album too yeah
another guy i would say that's my second
favorite album it's the purple rained
album that yeah it's really great album
did you see that in theaters yeah yeah
yeah yeah i saw pepperoni i saw all his
movies in theaters
my favorite was the one after that
it was under the cherry moon
moon and then that is like the worst
best movie ever i love under the cherry
moon that is just oh and that album is
great yes yes girls and boys
that's a great album uh
was i think i had had mine in my head
[ __ ]
oh i'll do
i'll do jackson 5 stop to love you save
stop love you say baby uh oh this is
gonna be a dope playlist yeah okay
i don't know you know what we should get
some white boy
oh yeah yeah yeah we had some white boy
acoustics some white boy you know what
what wait what's the one i i love
um
uh
love someone by lucas graham that's a
good one
oh and uh
oh i love my one of my jams is wild love
by james bay
that's a jam right there i'll do
eagle-eyed cherry save tonight since i
mentioned it now there you go how many
is that
that's ten wait let's get it wait you
said you had some white girl playlist oh
let's throw some white girls on there
you know you know we should yeah we have
equal opportunity
they already tweet that it's like where
did white girls say yeah what about
we're the white girls on this [ __ ]
ginger neutral playlists
man they keep changing spotify where you
can't see all your playlists anymore
yeah you have to do
uh when you go to you when you hit your
library you have to like slide over and
hit playlists
you see you know what you think they
just changed it thank you because i'll
be like where the hell is my damn
playlist
um
i have also i have a sing-along playlist
for my shower damn he got he got it all
yeah oh here we go white here you hear
this white girls
[Laughter]
oh you know what's a good white girl's
acoustic jam what it's called most girls
by haley steinfeld well i've heard that
one yeah that's a jam oh it's good i
like haley steinfeld she's a good
actress and a good singer i'll do
sixpence another richer breathe your
name
and like you know what you know who got
some good good acoustics it's katy perry
she does yeah if you're here if you like
did you hear her do her songs acoustic
she's actually a really good singer you
know so funny i i'm i'm a big justin
bieber fan i love i love him i love him
all the way but my favorite
favorites of his are his songs in
acoustic
i
i know i've met justin bieber many times
and i told him that myself really yeah i
said i was like you got all these people
around you but i bet you these dudes
don't got the acoustic album exactly and
not a lot of artists can pull that off
yeah they could they could just hit
their albums
he's got some good acoustic tracks yeah
yeah you know what i mean
uh
yeah let's do that yeah well eric
griffin thank you for coming on whatever
uh check out his podcast riffing with
griffin uh among many other things here
on twitch yeah river griffin and also my
other podcast jen the gin oh yeah we
took a break but it was like because i
got sick he got sick and then like
vacation but we're still coming back
with that it's me and matthew espinoza
uh so check that one out too and also
king of the sting
uh tour dates or anything um what does
this come out
thursday oh well yeah i'm gonna be in
michigan for uh i'll be in grand rapids
on friday and saturday okay grand rapids
friday and saturday eric griffin.com
yeah particularly all that stuff
bada bing bada boom thanks for coming
bro thank you appreciate it
you